Freunde der Sonne!
Manche von euch wissen,
dass ich normalerweise
gar keinen Alkohol trinke.
Und im Laufe dieses Videos
werdet ihr auch verstehen, warum.
Ihr kennt vielleicht das Gerücht,
dass Asiaten
keinen Alkohol vertragen.
Das ist kein rassistisches Klischee,
das ist einfach die Wahrheit.
Ca. 36 % der Süd-Ost-Asiaten, dazu
gehören auch Vietnamesen wie ich,
können Alkohol nicht richtig abbauen.
Also das trifft auch manchmal
auf Nicht-Asiaten zu,
aber in Asien ist das Phänomen
sehr weit verbreitet.
Ich hab mir hier
ca. 100 ml Weißwein eingeschenkt,
um euch zu demonstrieren,
was genau passiert,
wenn Asiaten Alkohol trinken.
Alles für die Wissenschaft. Prost!
Es ist übrigens 13.10 Uhr.
Oh Gott!
Da ich dieses Glas Wein
nicht einfach abziehen kann,
weil ich sonst
alles hier vollkotzen würde,
habe ich noch genug Zeit,
in der ich euch erklären kann,
was genau chemisch in Asiaten vor
sich geht, wenn sie Alkohol trinken.
Und um mich selbst zu challengen,
werden wir keine Grafiken einblenden,
sondern ich werde alles Erklärende
hier auf diesem Block selbst malen.
Was natürlich im Laufe des Videos
immer schwieriger werden wird.
Fangen wir doch vielleicht
erst mal damit an,
was mit normalen Menschen passiert,
wenn sie Alkohol trinken.
Okay. Oh Gott.
Das Wort "Alkohol" im Alltagsgebrauch
steht für einen bestimmten Alkohol,
nämlich Ethanol. Der sieht so aus.
Diese OH-Gruppe ist das,
was Alkohol ausmacht.
Und ein Alkohol
mit zwei C-Atomen ist Ethanol.
Ethanol ist nicht nur
mega schädlich für die Leber.
Man kann ab einer Blutkonzentration
von 3 Promille auch schon sterben.
Ja.
Mit Glück kotzt man vorher alles aus.
Mit Pech erstickt man an seiner eige-
nen Kotze, weil man bewusstlos ist.
Ansonsten kann man Tod durch
Alkoholvergiftung vermeiden,
indem man sich den Magen auspumpen
lässt. Auch ein angenehmer Eingriff.
Alkohol ist wirklich
also eine super Droge.
Boah Leute, mir wird schon ganz heiß.
Freunde der Sonne.
Ich weiß nicht genau,
wie viel ich getrunken habe,
seit die Aufnahme gestoppt hat,
aber mein Akku war leer
und ich habe nichts davon gemerkt.
Jetzt habe ich
gerade ganz viel erklärt.
Und es wurde nicht aufgenommen.
Ich habe hier noch
meine Zettel liegen, Moment.
Ethanol ist nicht
das einzige Problem.
Denn Ethanol wird im Körper
umgewandelt zu Acetaldehyd.
Mithilfe ...
das stimmt hier gar nicht.
Gut, dass ich das noch mal aufnehme.
Diese chemische Reaktion verläuft
mithilfe eines Enzyms namens ADH.
Enzyme sind sogenannte Katalysatoren.
D.h. Enzyme helfen einer chemischen
Reaktion, schneller zu verlaufen,
die ohne dieses Enzym
so gut wie nicht oder nur sehr
langsam verlaufen würde, okay?
Also Enzyme: Wichtig!
Acetaldehyd ist schlecht. Acetaldehyd
ist ein sogenanntes Mutagen.
Es verändert deine Gene, deine DNA
und bringt auch noch sämtliche ande-
re krebserregende Effekte mit sich.
Acetaldehyd: Schlecht!
Das Acetaldehyd wird weiterhin
abgebaut zu Essigsäure,
bzw. zu Azetaten.
Also genauer genommen den Salzen
der Essigsäure, aber egal.
Das ist der Grund,
warum man nach einer
durchzechten Nacht übersäuert ist
bzw. nach einem Nachmittag,
wo man Schönschlau-Videos aufnimmt.
Diese chemische Reaktion verläuft
auch mithilfe eines Enzyms namens
ALDH2. Aldehyd-Dehydrogenase 2.
Dieses Enzym ist
wie gesagt der Katalysator.
Ohne dieses Enzym kann die Reaktion
nur sehr langsam verlaufen.
Dieses Enzym
ist aufgebaut aus Proteinen
und bei Menschen wie mir
ist in diesem großen Protein
eine einzige Aminosäure vertauscht.
Aufgrund dieser einen
vertauschten Aminosäure ...
funktioniert das nicht mehr.
D.h. bei mir,
wenn ich auch nur wenig trinke,
ist die Konzentration von Acetaldehyd
in meinem Körper viel höher,
als bei Menschen,
bei denen das Acetaldehyd
direkt wieder abgebaut wird.
So.
Das Acetaldehyd führt jedenfalls
neben den DNA-Veränderungen
und dergleichen zu Herzrasen,
Übelkeit und dem
sogenannten "Asian Flush-Syndrom".
D.h. man wird rot.
Ich weiß nicht, bin ich schon rot?
Jedenfalls Asiaten haben immer
ein extrem hohes Level
an Acetaldehyd intus,
was außerdem recht lange anhält,
weil dieses Acetaldehyd wie gesagt
nur sehr langsam abgebaut wird.
D.h. Asiaten
werden sehr schnell betrunken
und bleiben auch
recht lange betrunken.
Jedenfalls deswegen
trink ich auch keinen Alkohol,
außer mal 100 ml Weißwein
für Schönschlau.
Geschafft!
Also diese ganze Situation hier ...
ich bin mega rot, mir ist sehr heiß,
mir ist ein bisschen schlecht,
Herzrasen, joa.
Nichtsdestotrotz:
Dieses Asian Flush-Syndrom muss
man letztendlich als Schutz ansehen.
Und so sehen das viele Experten auch.
Wegen dieser ganzen Situation hier
bin ich überhaupt nicht in der Lage,
größere Mengen Alkohol
zu mir zu nehmen.
Hinzu kommt, dass Alkohol
richtig kacke schmeckt,
wenn man nicht die Gelegenheit hat,
sich das mit der Zeit
langsam anzugewöhnen
und sich reinzugewöhnen.
Ganz ehrlich:
Alkohol schmeckt nach Lösungsmittel.
Tut mir leid, das ist einfach so.
Wie vertragt ihr Alkohol?
Ich gehe davon aus, besser als ich,
aber schreibt's in die Kommentare.
Zusammen mit euren Fragen,
die ihr gerne mal
in einem Video beantwortet hättet.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Nochmal: Bleibt sicher!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)